i keith olbermann in this is the
resistance the firing of bill o'reilly
was presidential impeachment by proxy
and it just might have shown us a
roadmap to presidential removal by
economic pressure for 18 years rumors
accusations lawsuits audio tapes
transcripts and millions of dollars in
settlements have swirled around this man
like dirt around pig pen from the
peanuts cartoon and yet only now he's
gone this commentary is only about
o'reilly to the degree that he and
others at fox like steve doocy and sean
hannity connect to donald trump in fact
or by context but that context is
absolutely startling for the first time
in his life o'reilly not only had a
president who was clearly pro sexual
harassment but that president was
arguably his only public personal friend
and that president openly defended him
and 14 days later he got fired how in
the hell do you let that happen to
yourself impeachment by proxy it has
been noted a million times the Trump was
elected in large part by the rage of
pent-up frustration suddenly released at
the ballot box
I have argued that there is a second
wave of ped up frustration far stronger
far more righteous than the first which
was summoned by the thwarting of the
ballot box the tax day March the March
for science and a thousand other outlets
of protest against this corruptible
garyun in the White House including this
one are all good and vital in their way
but not one of them can directly remove
Trump earlier than 2020 and yet we
should have seen this coming with the
women's March that organic anger against
Trump and every other Pig like him was
transcendent and it did not dissipate
just because of the reality that the
only thing that can cost president [ __ ]
crabber his job will have to be
something besides his particular V no
brand of misogyny and alleged abuse
towards women but Trump's mirror image
the bloated slow-moving troglodyte
playing grab-ass from behind a desk on
6th Avenue in New York every night the
bulletproof money making machine who
turned out to be at the whim of
advertisers who are themselves at the
whim of
customers all that was needed was one
focus of the anti-trump protests one
originally grassroots loosely organized
boycott and one last spark over the pile
of harassment tinder or rallies been
carefully assembling nearly since Fox
News began and it all conflagration the
day the New York Times calculated that
the full known price in settlements to
women heiress by O'Reilly had hit 13
million dollars that was on April 1st
also on April 1st it was reported Fox
had renewed O'Reilly's contract on April
3rd O'Reilly's lawyers threatened
lawsuits on April 5th the president said
O'Reilly did nothing wrong on April 18th
O'Reilly was emailing his lawyers he
wasn't going to take much more of this
from Fox on April 19th he was fired at
on April 24th somebody else would have a
show at 8:00 Eastern on Fox News for the
first time since O'Reilly replaced the
original host in that slot Catherine
crier in early 1997 three weeks in two
days and he was gone and he was gone
because women and men fed up not merely
with the continuing issue of misogyny
and harassment and punishment of women
in this country and in our workplaces
and in our schools and in our
legislatures and in the hierarchy of our
political structure but now correctly
also enraged that all of these
nauseating forces had a new champion a
president of sleaze in the White House
redirected their anger and cut off Bill
O'Reilly's economic balls in 23 days in
large part because they couldn't cut off
Donald Trump's economic balls it will be
fascinating to see what the Trump crowd
thinks of the new landscape in that
fantasy land of Fox News in which not
only is there no O'Reilly but in which a
Reilly personal friend of Trump was
removed by Fox News it will make many of
them furious furious at the women and
the advertisers and the boycotters and
the Liberals and the anti-trump forces
it will probably make more of them
indifferent because a that's how
television works but also because be if
they were willing to be served the
kool-aid by the likes of Sean Hannity
and little Tucker Carlson then Bill
O'Reilly really wasn't necessary was he
could it make a few of the mad at Trump
because he didn't do more for his friend
than theirs
maybe could it make a few of them think
that if Fox would really fire O'Reilly
even just as economic self-protection
that this question of how men speak
about and treat women really matters
perhaps could it make just a couple of
them wonder if this subject is bad
enough to remove O'Reilly maybe it
should be bad enough to remove Trump I'm
not betting on that one O'Reilly will
reappear somewhere if he wants Fox will
not be destroyed that new contract they
had just signed with O'Reilly may have
saved them 50 maybe even 75 million
dollars because under the old one they
could not fire him for harassment
as they just did moving forward the real
questions begin with what will those
viewers think what will Fox think what
will advertisers think about the other
accusations against Fox hosts Steve
Doocy and Sean Hannity to see who I
guess is the centerpiece of that weird
morning show that Trump loves Fox and
Friends more reminiscent of a poorly
rehearsed infomercial than an actual
news program Ducey was accused of
creating a hostile work environment by
his departed co-host gretchen carlson
and last Friday Fox's long ago go to
Islamophobic guest Debbie Schlussel went
on the radio in Tulsa to describe a
weird encounter with sean hannity in
detroit more than 10 years ago he tried
to get me to go back with him to the
hotel after the show she said after that
I wasn't booked on his show again and he
called me and yelled at me this kind of
stuff is all over the place at Fox News
and with anything that has to do with
Sean Hannity Russell also claimed Hannah
DS one-time executive producer now Fox
News co-president bill shine was and
again I'm quoting Debbie salsals Tulsa
radio interview the pimp for Roger Ailes
he was the fixer for Bill O'Reilly
unquote Hannity has since angrily denied
everything and shlussel later clarified
that somehow she's not accusing him here
of sexual harassment so what matters now
is how in cloudier circumstances how Fox
treats these stories and whether the
boycott machine that proved so effective
against a
Riley can now be turned against Dulce or
Hannity or both but lurking behind all
of this particularly if Dulce or Hannity
meet any kind of fate similar to that of
O'Reilly is a phenomenon the political
effectiveness of which cannot yet be
assessed if consumers pressuring
advertisers pressuring a television
network can destroy a powerful man long
and angrily unapologetic about his
treatment of women can that process be a
template for use against Trump is there
enough consumer based pressure in this
country not truly political but
essentially just economic to hamstring
Trump's businesses or in the best case
scenario to force him to resign the
presidency the man has never had a
coherent thought in his head except
about how to make money and how to take
it from others what if the money could
be taken from him what if a boycott that
powerful could be summoned could you
starve every business that deals with
Trump could you crash his empire and not
stop unless he quits we could try the
whole game plan does not spring fully
formed from the ground before my eyes
but what if it's there somewhere what if
the firing of Bill O'Reilly as
presidential impeachment by proxy could
form the basis for the real removal of a
corrupt and misogynistic president
resist peace